any questions or comments to be
interesting to see thing about it on
Saturday was gonna say something I think
it you you can see on your technique in
the videos you're always moving in
proportion with me everyone saw my seat
on the mat with other people but it's
very rare to see the harmonization far
away close in the technique after the
technique its wing techniques and I'm
wondering whether those skills or I
don't know the same thing I would say
yeah they're very much related there's a
lot of overlap so in the sense that when
we talked about it with sube I had asked
you two to begin with a material
blending but to understand that it is
ultimately about an immaterial
intangible communion that must happen
and so even to elaborate a little bit on
that spiritually the Spirit has no
materiality this thing we call nature
all that force that stands in between
before and after the tree and the leaf
on the Acorn
this divine we we try to describe in
negative terms this big inner aspects of
ourself that we feel are the most real
but I cannot point to I cannot touch I
cannot surgically remove or add to my
being the the those invisible
gravitational forces that make up the
loves in our lives all of that is beyond
our touch
and it would be if it would be no we can
accept all that but somehow when it
comes time to fighting we only think in
terms of the punch we don't think in
terms of the beam and all those
invisible things but you have to because
pita life is faster than tongue speed of
life is faster than a tangible sensing
of a stimuli and then a responding of my
own stimuli and the idea you know like a
flower a guy he has an idea it's such as
you know snake-oil science or he says
we'll yeah that's true so what we need
to do is use a primitive reflex and
that's gonna make us fast enough and
it's all not have written on
that you know we are not the first
culture to discover the flinch response
other societies other cultures
throughout history clearly understood it
but they rejected it they rejected it
because it's not tactically viable in
the end
and they went for this other thing is
the other thing that it it is true if I
have a love affair and I and I have it
existing only at the level of
materiality you're not gonna feel love
nor will your partner in fact we define
those love affairs that are only
material right we typically say they're
not they're not love affairs they're
one-night stands
you're just using the person they're
just using you so in the love affair it
is about this immaterial connection that
allows you to know or to cano without it
being told to you of what your partner
needs wants you're you're able to elicit
the proper response
outside of its matter and outside of its
clearly stated form
well what did what is that well human
beings have things like intention ideas
want fears there's a person that is
attacking you stop having those things
no they have those things too so why
can't I into it you might want to say
well you can into it when you learn more
about that person in a combat situation
is so quick you don't have time to into
it and that seems to make sense only
when you look at long old relationships
yes there might be some old couples who
can into it but the majority of them
could give a what the other person
is thinking right they've done into
eating they can into it they there's no
need for it
and that tells me that duration alone is
not it just in the same way you will
meet that special person and you'll go
you'll under some variation on the frame
I feel like I've known you all my life
why can you two why can you feel that
way right off the bat well again
whatever the reason might be it still
says that I can do it right immediately
I don't need a lifetime to be able to
sense and into it from this unsaid
immaterial information what to do what
should be done I think that's very
important because when it comes time to
union or musubi or communion with the
divine
which is immaterial and silence if I
don't posit the human capacity for that
communion in the face of that silence
and in material nature then I don't have
any relationship with the divine I don't
have any spiritual maturity I don't
because you can take that one if I if I
take that one away then of course my own
spirit where is it what is it it's all
those things we point to be on our
matter beyond our intellect beyond our
words well if it to you cannot
surgically remove it and or put it in
and it is not going to write it all out
for you yet
you must find a way of relating to it
you must find a way of knowing its wants
its needs its fears its intentions so
communication right which is a kind of
musubi and the way that I'm using it
communication is possible
human beings have the capacity to
communicate with immaterial thing and
that doesn't change whether the person
is attacking me dancing with me making
love to me or arguing with me once I
love for that possibility then well what
gets in the way of that what we always
say you're not present what do you we
mean by that you are somewhere else
doing something else being something
else such that the information that is
contained therein you are not able to
sense it we that's how we define
presence it's an inverse or a negative
understanding your presence is is not
positively defined it is negatively
defined meaning how do I know why when
I'm present when you are able to sense
all the information that is there how do
I know when I'm not present when there's
information that is there but you
weren't able to sense it you understand
so we refer to that in Buddha
centeredness right we could even
understand it when we talk about machine
because machine is or no mind is the
capacity to not be pulled by any one
thing away from the totality of
information that is there so when I'm in
the fight if my mind is captured by one
thing again negatively understanding
that that means I do not have the
totality I'm missing part of the message
when I have the totality of the message
it means I'm not pulled by any one thing
and when I'm not pulled by any one thing
and I have the totality of the message I
have machines so if you if you look at
your tea water and every time it's not
fluid it's not natural it's force you're
pulling pushing you're early you're late
you'll always find that you're stuck on
one thing and you will always find then
simultaneously that you're not getting
the whole of the message and then you
will find that you cannot blend with
that person because getting the whole of
the message is itself musubi at that
immaterial level so I will I don't have
to subi at that a material level what
are the odds of me having musubi at a
material level what could happen but if
it did it's what coincidence it's just a
lot your your onion present attached
fear driven mind whatever the reason why
you lost wishing caused a particular
response tension again and they happen
to walk into tension under and it works
fine but it's just coincidence then it
happens those things happen in nature
but that's not what Google is after
so when we use the phrase in English
meaning into it intuition now we're
talking about being able to understand
comprehend and decide a certain course
of action upon what at first glance
appears to be only part of the
information and at first glance when
someone's attacking you the strike the
actual physical strike is only part of
the information so it might look like as
you saw I'm moving moving moving before
the strike comes yes because I'm already
in communion with them they've already
done a lot of things they have shifted
their way they have inhale they have
exhaled they have their glances focused
in a certain direction and every one of
those things for example means that
something else is not going to happen
and so you can move into certain areas
knowing because of how you shifted your
way your inhalation pattern just for
example where you look prior to odds are
that I can move here and you're not
going to be able to do anything about
when you can do that the techniques are
become effortless and you might say you
might want to say now my Aikido is
effective no your Aikido was that
immaterial musubi
it's not now now now I can do iki oh
that's a that's a very crude
understanding of the art right so now
now when she grabs my wrist I could do
Iko Iko started way long time ago if you
wait to now when he grabs my wrist I can
do eet you you will not do eat you you
will not do eat yo unless what your
coincidental or do things we always
you're stronger and you're faster than
that person okay but if you're doing it
coincidentally and you're doing it
because you're stronger or you're faster
than that person is that Aikido no it's
not and if Akio is an Aikido technique
are you really doing iki oh no you're
not you're doing some armbar do you
understand so all your training has to
lead to this understanding of them with
sube whether it's Marshall you're here
for Marshall reasons or whether you're
here for spiritual reasons you you
cannot have your understanding of the
art or of its key concepts like musubi
limited by any kind of material world
view it must go beyond that and the
examples like name you that are to
encourage you it's not such a strange
concept we have a material reading of
things of them
nation of immaterial information all the
time in fact most of the time most of
the ways that we're living are not based
upon the intellectual verbal material
bits of information it's just the
economy's driven by that so we are
culture to hurry up and go to school to
produce material intellectual things so
that we can sell them but most of your
life is not at all geared on the you
couldn't even win if that is the way
that you live not one bit
you're looking at the problem of right
it's the problem of spontaneity isn't it
right it's the problem of talking with
psyche be a spontaneous application of
wisdom assume you have all the
information then that assumes that you
are able to receive all of the
information that to me that is the
Warriors interest in zen was the effect
that attachment that attachment to any
one thing when he one piece of
information has upon wisdom has upon the
choosing of right thought right speech
right action for the warrior right
action the warrior is interested in
Buddhism's mind theory because it makes
sense my capacity to observe the
totality is hindered by by attachment to
this one thing or that two things or
this thing or that thing and that causes
my martial performance to degenerate
which causes my statistical probability
for surviving this to go way down we
still see it today in law enforcement
that's the buzzword is mindfulness
because not being mindful not being
present and he's stuck on any one thing
still gets people killed and it still
ruins relationships
so I don't think we're talking about
some you know magic not like the force
of Star Wars which is why I give you
those everyday things everyday examples
of where we relate to immaterial things
all the time we value them all the time
we prioritize them all the time so it's
not like the force it's not a magic I'm
advocating here but you must be
motivated to move beyond your material
limitation to other people it will look
like you knew right in a paranormal way
but they're just not there they're not
operating them you you you don't you
don't know you don't know in that way
that's why it looks odd to them or fake
to them the problem of Marshall
practicality jumping ahead is not one of
technique it is one of this to know in
this way once once you can know in this
way you don't need to know techniques
you're not restricted by form or style
kind of like that but pianist gamer for
notes
she just goes off and don't think for a
second that she she had all that written
out in her head that no she got a little
bit of it then started playing and now
she is responding to what she's
listening to him herself play they can
the same way if you if you were to ask
can you do it again she's gone no I
can't do it again right well she's in
the moment she's present but probably if
you film her and she's watching it and
she goes back to what this is I can see
that this would make me do that and that
would make me be back but she's able to
put out the product that melody in a
spontaneous way without having the music
in front of her the directions and all
that kind of stuff that was no different
than Takuma psyche that is the same
thing as G was free you're free
attachment is always the kind of
enslavement right and so machine is
always going to be a kind of Jean a kind
of freedom
so if you sum up like yeah not a strange
thing it's not a magic thing that's not
a superstition thing it's not even
anti-scientific it might be anti
scientistic but it's not anti-scientific
and I need it to understand my art I
cannot do my art without this capacity
to have communion at that early point
with anyone anything anytime
it's not an alternative to marshal
training it is the heart of martial
training they the hippie I coca that
come to the Arts with this very
adolescent view of non-resistance
and the art of peace is that adolescent
view very philosophically immature view
like to contrast this okay you can
either do martial arts where you're
going to kick the crap out of someone or
you can do this sube but that's that's
what how dabbler is always talk they
know the words but they don't have the
understanding and so they're like kids
they're like kids we kids here mommy and
daddy talking and they're playing their
little doll game they use the words but
they have no concept of how that works
and so you get these very strange ideas
that I can either be sube I can either
have them supey
or I can have Marsha ality and that's
not true in fact I'm saying the exact
opposite you cannot have Marsha allottee
without musubi and any musubi that
cannot exist under a Marcia Lee intense
situation is not musubi it's likely
coincidence by which we mean it's inside
our ego attachment so it's not musubi
so let that motivate you yes learn your
forms but no you're supposed to give the
on form not stuck in form so take the
technique we had we just did one slight
modification the chitin nugget don't go
for the arm and it's explaining to you
that you didn't you don't have the arm
like in katate dori and the hip is more
effective it is way more effective if
you ever watch me when I'm not out to
teach you guys anything and I'm just
doing my Katya Maggie I always bring
that arm writing to this now I'm going
to push the hip with their arm
do you see how that the hip is a direct
manipulation of what needs to be
manipulated the arm is an indirect
manipulation so the arm indirect
manipulations allow you to almost they
work like a pulley in the sense that you
won't require as much strength to affect
whatever it is you want to affect but
you have a delay and you'll have slack
all that kind of stuff so in this case I
make the hip very light how how is it
hit made very life by bringing the head
around there ain't nothing on the hip so
when you were training in between you
saw he spun around and he's spinning
around on you did you you're not pushing
it but that tells me how light the hip
is now so you bring the head around and
that part is the same in keyhole aza and
in the the technique we did tonight the
oil was a variation right counter and
better pen variation but yet even though
everyone's instructed do the head
explain the benefit of the head the
technique doesn't actually
doesn't make it any worse how many
people went for the arm but for the arm
because you're trapped in four you're
trapped in form and that is always one
of the downsides of any system of
learning it doesn't attempt to change
whether it's Buddhism Zen or brutal you
need form but you must go beyond form
every art is a kind of poison but like
medicines right take them up it'll work
you take too much it starts to kill you
that kind of poison
- no different then how do I not take
too much you have to always understand I
am learning in a form to go beyond a
form I am learning Aikido to not have
Aikido and it's not until then that you
do have Aikido because Aikido a form
it's not Aikido so every single Aikido
cup must chase after that deconstruction
of form yes go after form but you must
also chase after a deconstruction of
form and a reconciliation of form and
non form otherwise you don't have a
practice you just have an exercise
yes
this shoe honey again you see that is
what the classic Warriors understood and
what makes things practical not
technique but mine capacity the anyone
who who fights for real who really does
it like they've mastered it they know
the real problem is spontaneity the real
problem is form the real problem is the
riddle of form and non form that causes
hesitation mismatched tactical
application poor strategy but a lot of
people don't fight for real or a lot of
people don't fight long enough to
realize that's what's happening you know
when you when life's on the line and you
mess up you make the wrong technical
tactical decision you better believe
your mind starts spinning like crazy on
why you made that wrong tactical
decision it does not go like you might
see in a sport application does not go
to you know what you should have chosen
instead it's very concerned with why did
you choose so wrong so wrong li not just
what should I have chosen instead you
become very preoccupied with that
because the consequences
are just operating at that level the
level of nightmares right you you'll
wake up with sweats and dreams and you
you know work where you survived but you
knew it was luck and so in the dreams
you don't survive
are you done
so the ancient warrior was more like
what stopping me from using the
information that I have right in a in a
spontaneous live situation and it's a
problem mine
not a problem love technique so to be
obsessed with technique or to limit
myself technique is really just apart
from the ancient masters and that that
just seems crazy too early releases they
know this mind stuff and totally be
solved if you just learned a practical
art
so we have articles on shoe hobby on the
website go go back and read them just
even to get an idea of what we're
talking about here we also have the Tuck
lon his book library there so check it
out
it's available on audiobook that one's a
little dance though I don't recommend
the audiobook for the unfettered mind
but get the book it's a penguin clapping
that's like five bucks or four bucks
right down in Chapter one we'll get you
in
the technique is that the point of the
story of
yeah that that's the point of the story
but obviously you need to have shoot you
have to start with you cannot not star
this year I think
maybe people war isn't no a different
language would be able to and I wish
they would comment on the problem that
Bruce Lee had when he was understood
this problem when he exposed himself to
writers like Cochrane and others and
thinkers and we saw the problem of form
in spontaneity and spontaneous
application and so ok but what do I
teach you now by it my problem is formed
and I make my art about freeing you from
formal what do I start with though and I
think those early people that were
coming after him you know that's why you
started seeing inclusion from other arts
because you have to start somewhere and
even in in Buddhism you see that you'll
have a lot of people who are who will
grasp this concept intellectually of
machine and then they start I'm not
attached to nothing
right except they don't see you're
attached to non-attachment
and they might eventually venture into a
actual zen temple and they cannot fathom
how many rules and how much confinement
that goes on there and how everything is
ritualized and the schedule is all set
and everything has a way of doing it and
a way is not to be done and it's
shocking to them right and today I seems
not of Zen but it's because they don't
truly they have not truly reconciled for
me so when I do if I'm in GU was up if
you think that Takuma CIT is never doing
EQ Nico funcle' yonkyo but always making
up something that's never been created
before then you are attached to non
attachment
you're attached to the idea of non form
and that is no better than to be a test
to form it is still as blinding it is
still as unaware it's exactly the same
spiritually
and so then okay
inversely what does that mean you know
what it means it means that when I am
when I had truly reconciled form in non
form when I'm at me
that might emote Laza is as much G water
as my G was a it can't be key one was up
so if I'm doing my technique and I've
picked my eco in advance and it's
working because it's coincidence that
would be attachment to form but if I go
and I say whoops don't do eco that's a
form technique do something up that's
attachment to non form but if I blend
with the person that's coming in I have
communion with them and they fall into
what some observers going to look at and
go to that video that would be the
reconciliation of form anomaly what that
is what that that rejection of form for
an attachment to non form is what I
would call a part of that adolescent
understanding the rebel without a cause
is what that is that's why I call it
adolescent because you're like a
teenager who just I'm going to do the
opposite and not realizing the exact
opposite isn't exactly the same heads of
tails it's still a quarter that kind of
thing
so what I'm asking you to get beyond
form it's not to reject form that's not
what we mean well hence the phrase a
reconciliation of form of non form
you're probably going what the hell does
that mean well I think you can at least
confuse it doesn't mean to reject form
we could have said that and we didn't
say that and it would be a total
misunderstanding of
and if you going out here and you're
doing G was that and you're trying it's
hard to not do a cure as if you were at
the beginning of your so-called practice
to do Eco you would be as much unnatural
right in your g1 your technique would be
as much force as it would be or wouldn't
be so form is not something in the end I
have to reject all outright it is
something I have to reconcile but I
cannot be satisfied with form nor can I
be satisfied with non form in that sense
then I can start with form I just can't
and you'll see lately was this week I've
been telling you stop doing the
technique feel feel the technique feel
what the person is needs to have done
that is there's a communion between my
GU and Mikey on stop operating and this
is where my arm goes on tension not yet
why why it does when you're trying to
learn the concepts or the architecture
at an abstract level put in application
if my you kids not there for that then I
have to do what they're requiring so
with that the video you saw all those
different variations right there was one
variation I've never done before I
looked at ago oh that's a pretty neat
and one where I was on one side and
stepped immediately to the other side
was really pretty cool like Don I've
never done it before
but that's where they were going it was
just too much energy and I would to go
panic and all that would make it a
Marshall so let me go to the other side
they push it on one side
probably not push it on the other side
right
so we're trying to learn I got to get
stronger
I gotta learn commitment I gotta learn
sacrifice I gotta learn to navigate
myself and my life and the daily
practice which seems huge it's
overwhelming isn't it okay because the
reconciliation of form of non form is
what we we people on the way call that's
what we're referring to when we say it
takes a lifetime showing up a daily
practice the commitment that doesn't
take a lifetime that even happens in a
snap you might take a lifetime it does
not it does not take that
so let's put this in perspective
get yourself where it needs to be where
you need to be get yourself at the foot
of the mountain some of us are in the
neighboring city not at the foot of
Mount Fuji some of us are on the
Shinkansen going by and looking at Mount
Fuji out the window you have to get at
the foot and this is the mountain
shuhada
form deconstruction of form
reconciliation of form in non form
there's no heart outside of that you'll
get some benefits but
that is the heart